Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos durante el primer gobierno de
los talibanes en Afganistán entre 1996 y
2001 millones de mujeres quedaron por
fuera del sistema educativo un método de
escuelas clandestinas empezó a operar a
lo largo del país para educar a miles de
jóvenes que más tarde se convertirían en
líderes de cambio en las últimas dos
décadas con el regreso de los talibanes
se ha reanudado parcialmente su vieja
política de excluir a las mujeres de la
educación se calcula que más de un
millón de estas mujeres entre 12 y 20
años han quedado por fuera del sistema
escolar desde septiembre de 2021 la
enseñanza clandestina ha regresado para
dar apoyo a estas jóvenes especialmente
en kabul donde miles de mujeres asisten
a cursos con la esperanza de que se
levanten las restricciones y puedan
volver a las aulas Catalina Gómez Ángel
autora de este reportaje junto a iquival
Nuri y mazuchinay nos acompaña hoy la
saludo Catalina qué pretenden los
talibanes con esta política de no dejar
estudiar a las mujeres
hay varias teorías primero demuestra la
gran división que tienen ellos algunas
activistas dicen que incluso Esta es una
estrategia para
diversificarla o llamar la atención de
la comunidad internacional que que viene
presionando porque estas mujeres puedan
vuelvan a las aulas para ellos poder
aumentar la presión contra el resto de
la población sin que realmente
se preste atención en en otros en otros
Campos también lo que demuestra es que
realmente es su política
patriarcal de la que no quieren que las
mujeres tomen una participación en la
sociedad entonces lo que ellos hacen no
es realmente bloquear toda la educación
sino que rompen la cadena de las mujeres
que están en bachillerato o en
Secundaria y entonces eventualmente no
va a haber quien siga adelante para una
educación
Universitaria en el futuro lo que trae
grandes problemas para el país como lo
vemos por ejemplo con los médicos en
este reportaje ya volvemos contigo
Catalina aquí la historia
[Música]
la jornada empieza temprano en kabul a
las 6 ese grupo de alumnas ya recibe su
primera lección del día
te vas un estudiante de secundaria
excluidas del sistema educativo por los
talibanes
este instituto privado es uno de los
tantos centros que desafían la orden del
gobierno y les dan clases de manera
clandestina con el objetivo de no dejar
morir su sueño de llegar a la
universidad
yo quiero ser doctora en el futuro
porque quiero ayudar a la gente que vive
en Afganistán
quiero trabajar en hospitales y trabajar
por toda la gente de Afganistán
el tiempo juegan su contra a las 8
tienen que dejar las aulas para dar
espacio a los hombres pero sobre todo no
despertar sospechas entre las
autoridades que hasta ahora miran hacia
otro lado si los talibanes no nos dejan
estudiar en los colegios no hay problema
podemos estudiar en muchos centros
podemos estudiar por nuestra cuenta
podemos estudiar con libros muchas
clases de libros
[Aplausos]
lo que sucede nos hace sentir muy mal
porque la única manera que podemos
mejorar el país tener algo en el futuro
es solo la educación si los hombres
estudian y las mujeres no o las mujeres
estudian y los hombres no lo hacen no
vamos a mejorar y no vamos a tener un
buen futuro y nuestro país nunca va a
progresar si sigue de esta manera la
suerte del instituto puede cambiar Si
las autoridades deciden ordenar su
cierre Así que los profesores intentan
que las jóvenes se dispersen rápidamente
tiene el tiempo contado para llegar a
otro Centro Educativo allí preparan a
jóvenes que cursaban el último año de
bachillerato cuando llegaron los
talibanes
base
el primer día que vinieron los talibanes
yo iba al colegio cubierta conchador y
muchas esperanzas después de dos años de
cuarentena estaba feliz en el colegio
pero al llegar nos dijeron que no estaba
abierto que estaba prohibido para
nosotros Así que ese fue el día más
negro de mi vida iba al colegio llena de
sueños que luego quedaron arruinados más
de un millón de jóvenes entre 12 y 18
años no pueden regresar al colegio
estas jornadas tienen como objetivo
darles motivación
al principio fue muy difícil para
nosotros manejar esta situación porque a
pesar de que vinieron al centro y se
unieron a las clases estaban deprimidas
no tenían ninguna Esperanza perdieron
todo lo que las motivaba en su vida así
que empezamos a trabajar con ellas
tenemos un equipo
nuestras colegas trabajan con ellas
regularmente con el objetivo de cambiar
sus ideas y manera de pensar y ahora
puede ver la cara de estas jóvenes como
son optimistas sobre el futuro como
quieren ser alguien en el futuro
y Alda la profesora de inglés en la
universidad hasta la llegada de los
talibanes al igual que sucedió con la
mayoría de mujeres en Afganistán perdió
su trabajo
después de un par de meses encerrada en
su casa decide unirse a programas que
ayudaron a las mujeres especialmente a
jóvenes a las que los talibanes habían
dejado sin educación sin otra opción en
su vida más que casarse
mi objetivo siempre ha sido ser doctora
y nunca voy a abandonarlo no voy a dejar
que los cambios alrededor afecten mi
manera de pensar lo único que quiero es
servir a mi comunidad no importa si es
una República un emirato islámico debo
perseguir mis sueños
el objetivo de este centro es que este
grupo de alumnas pueda continuar sus
estudios superiores
este año el gobierno talibán ha hecho
una excepción y permite que las mujeres
que ya cursaban el último grado se
presentan al conjuro o el examen de
acceso a la universidad
[Música]
tenemos mucha suerte de que encontramos
la manera de Seguir nuestra educación en
este centro
Pero sabemos que hay muchas mujeres en
Afganistán que no puede ir al colegio
durante el primer gobierno talibán entre
1996 y 2001 ninguna mujer tuvo acceso a
la educación
muy lentamente regresaron a las aulas
después de que Estados Unidos invadió
Afganistán expulsó a los talibanes del
poder en el marco de la llamada guerra
contra el terrorismo
miles de jóvenes fueron educadas gracias
a decenas de proyectos que se crearon en
el país pero muchas otras nunca entraron
al sistema educativo
cuando los talibanes retomaron el poder
3.7 millones de niños no eran educados
el 60% de ellos mujeres y solo el 16% de
los colegios eran femeninos
el clérigo malaw Ibrahim abrió esta
madraza o escuela coránica para educar a
niñas que estaban por fuera del colegio
en un barrio Popular de kabul
su estrategia para convencer a los
padres fue combinar la educación formal
con la enseñanza religiosa que es
extremadamente importante para millones
de familias en Afganistán
aprendió el valor de la educación de su
madre décadas de guerra han dejado a
millones de mujeres viudas en Afganistán
su padre fue asesinado cuando él era
pequeño y ella tuvo que educarlo
se interesa un palacio nuevo
muchas de estas jóvenes también ven
amenazadas su educación como
consecuencia de la pobreza que es cada
vez mayor desde la llegada de los
talibanes
las Naciones Unidas consideran que el
95% de la población pasa hambre
esta cabina estas dos mujeres escuchan
los problemas inquietudes de personas
que llaman desde varias provincias de
Afganistán
hacen parte del equipo de radio begun un
proyecto independiente de sinagoga apoyo
a las mujeres y que fue puesto en marcha
cinco meses antes de la llegada de los
talibanes
Incluso en las ciudades estamos viendo
que las mujeres están en casa no pueden
salir ni por su trabajo ni por sus
estudios
incluso las niñas las adolescentes están
en casa Y esto no es bueno por su salud
mental
Tratamos de darles coraje y decirles que
no están solos
[Música]
[Risas]
esta noche el noticiero recoge una vez
más la división que existe entre
funcionarios talibanes sobre la
educación de las mujeres
si bien hay un sector que apoya su
regreso a las aulas incluido decenas de
líderes religiosos en las provincias el
ala más radical a la que pertenece el
ministro de la prevención del pecado y
la promoción de la virtud la rechaza
de Cara a la comunidad internacional los
talibanes insisten que están ultimando
los últimos detalles para permitir que
las mujeres regresen a las aulas como ya
lo hicieron en las universidades
las exigencias para reabrirlas fue que
las mujeres y los hombres reciban clases
por separado
esta Facultad de Medicina de la
Universidad de kabul tuvo que habilitar
un edificio exclusivamente para ellas
Afganistán necesita al menos 3000
doctores al año y cientos de mujeres
estudiantes sueñan con serlo
esto lo entiende bien el doctor fasal
que fue nombrado director de la Facultad
de Medicina hace pocos meses
si no tenemos educación Primaria para
las mujeres en Afganistán no podrán
seguir su camino
hacia la educación superior en el campo
de la medicina
y esto es un gran reto para nosotros
actualmente
ojalá que este asunto sea solucionado en
el futuro cercano
esta tarde sujal coordina un club de
lectura sobre la importancia del arte
una de las actividades que más sospechas
despiertan entre los talibanes que los
últimos días siguen de cerca el trabajo
de estos centros educativos puestos en
marcha por la asociación catalana
puentes por la paz liderada por la
escritora afgana la diagonal
Cuando leo un libro me siento muy bien
muchas veces leo libros de motivación y
me hacen mucho bien siento que puedo
lograr mis objetivos
en medio de la actividad sujal informa
las alumnas que tienen que parar le han
avisado que un grupo de talibanes han
estado en otro de los centros y vienen
hacia este lugar les pide que se retiren
muy lentamente sin llamar la atención
tenemos permiso pero no sabemos que van
a preguntar estamos haciendo la
actividad correcta no tenemos miedo de
nuestras actividades Pero tenemos miedo
por la seguridad de las chicas
Un día después la encontramos en otro
lugar de kabul cuenta que han decidido
cerrar todos los centros por un mes
tocaron la puerta muy duro
los profesores abrieron y habían tres
personas personas del sector talibán sin
tener ningún permiso
ni siquiera un papel entraron a la casa
y directamente preguntaron qué pasaba
allí
dijeron que habían recibido la noticia
de que ustedes hacen actividades
ilegítimas que están tratando desviar a
los jóvenes
es la mañana del viernes 30 de
septiembre y decenas de ambulancias
transportan a jóvenes heridos en el
ataque suicida al centro educativo Cash
en el barrio de barchí en kabul
A las afueras de los hospitales reina La
angustia estas listas recogen los
nombres de los primeros admitidos al
menos 53 estudiantes murieron y sin
quedaron heridos
horas más tarde los cuerpos empiezan a
llegar al cementerio la mayoría de los
fallecidos son jóvenes mujeres que se
encontraban en las primeras filas de una
clase que tenía 900 alumnos cuando un
suicida se inmoló entre las fallecidas
está samira de 17 años que soñaba con
ser doctora
su padre muestra la foto que lleva en el
celular
ella trabajaba y estudiaba muy duro la
mayoría de las veces ocupaba la primera
posición hoy iba a ser una simulación
del examen del concurso y por eso fue
muy temprano al centro educativo puedo
decir que era una gran estudiante
algunas veces estudiaba hasta las 12 o 1
de la mañana
metros más arriba esta mujer Observa el
funeral su hija Lima estaba en el mismo
instituto esta mañana ella trabaja en el
cementerio para pagar el colegio de Lima
que también quiere ser doctora
[Música]
mi madre me ha dicho esta mañana que no
siga con mis clases pero yo quiero ir el
sueño de ellos es ese que no vayamos
pero yo quiero continuar estudiando es
mi objetivo y no quiero incumplirlo
este nuevo gobierno talibán ha cerrado
las clases para las jóvenes adolescentes
pero no la fortaleza de miles de ellas
que no parecen dispuestas a dejarse
vencer
estamos de vuelta con Catalina en el
reportaje vemos la pasión de las jóvenes
por estudiar Cuánto puede durar este
impulso Y qué efecto tiene la presión de
la comunidad internacional
Es realmente
impresionante ver esa esa necesidad y
esa pasión y esa
entendimiento de estas jóvenes
especialmente en kabul donde estuvimos
por la necesidad de estudiar y estudiar
alto nivel la mayoría quieren ser
doctoras como lo vimos o aspirar a altas
carreras y realmente también sus
familias en ese sentido han cambiado en
los últimos años y las están apoyando
sin embargo por ejemplo
atentados como ese que presenciamos al
final del reportaje hacen que cada vez
más familias tengan temor de dejarlas
asistir a estos centros educativos y
obviamente cada vez son más de estas
mujeres que las van sacando de este
sistema ya sea por temor o porque
piensan sus familias que no tienen
ningún sentido de que ella lo sigan
intentando si eventualmente no van a
poder llegar a la universidad Gracias
Catalina hasta aquí reporteros de la
semana Recuerda que para sintonizar esta
y las emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]